what time
[Music]
ready stop
please
foreign
had a key moment
plan for the first phase of the African
Union
this period will be especially important
given the ongoing hostilities in the
region
including instant oil in sedan
in the persistent threat of al-shaba
I've been encouraged to hear of the
continued success of the current phase
of the somali-led operation against
al-shabab in central
Somali
our corporation on
these operations is crucial and we stand
ready as your partner
as you defend yourselves against these
dangerous and violence forces
and our security Corporation is vital in
other areas too
that includes effective responses to
climate shocks such as
the current draw which has meant
so much hunger and Devastation for your
people
Mr President I also appreciate the
transparency of your security
initiatives
and the inclusion of key International
Partners in the planning
somali-led transition
as we look to 2025 and Beyond
I remain grateful for the willingness of
your government
and your people to host our forces in
Somalian
Mr President let me thank you again for
your administration's leadership to
drive progress
on these key security issues again it's
great to have you here thanks for making
a trip and I look forward to today's
discussion over
thank you thank you very much Mr
secretary for me it's a great pleasure
and honor
this is
giving us this opportunity to come and
share with your situation Mr secretary
as you are aware somebody has been in a
very unique situation for the last three
decades and throughout this period the
United States has been with us at the
times
is a very prolonged situation but now is
the time that we ever had
the hope that this is going to end soon
I would like to extend my gratitude to
the United States government
Somali people in our fight against as
well as the profession of critical
humanitarian and development
is the defeating of al-shabaab
requires more than capable and effective
security forces but also an inclusive
State Building
process and ability of the state to
provide Clinical Services to the public
my Administration has made strides over
the last year in these areas
for Godly became successive Somali
administrations including my previous
one
we were not able to reach political
agreement on funny issues of the State
Building
due to
fear of failure or lack of competition
or many other reasons since my election
we have the six successive National
conservative Council buildings
that resulted in a consensus agreements
with the federal member status on power
sharing
judicial model of the country
federalism National Security
architecture and the Electoral moral of
the democratic Somalia
Somali National Army has recovered more
than 70 locations from al-shaba in
partnership with local communities
estimated
program have resulted in a couple of
Strike Force so that has been the tip of
the spare the strip of this pill of SNL
offensive federalist
Japanese has proven to be very very
successful Endeavor and we are very much
grateful for that effort in the last
decade or so
we have also improved Urban security to
enhancing intelligence efforts resulting
in a market reduction
over the past seven months this has been
also a new area that Somalia has shown
Improvement
over the last six months the government
and its International Partners have over
240 stabilization activities and the two
states liberated from al-shaba
stabilization was critical because of
it is the link between the state and the
people
was
being denied access of any public
service form more than two decades
is the second phase of the
what we are with within without Shabbat
the national forces that deployed
key planning and operational expertise
that are currently positioned at joint
conclusion command in
planning together
you know start your team in the ground
are also aware of that and they have
been invited a number of times in the in
that type of work in that Center of
coordination
of course slide setbacks has been
experienced due to rainy seasons and
and due to our resistance mainly we have
advanced security reform through the
establishment of active interagency task
force that is developing sustainable and
sustainability and affordability models
for financing of our national security
forces in the future our midterm fiscal
policy goal is for our current courses
to be covered by our domestic Revenue by
secretary
Somalia has been in a
tuition as I said earlier we are again
and again very much grateful for the
support provided by the United States
many issues that I have raised with you
last time when I visited the United
States is still standing but so far we
are so good and we are very much
satisfied for the level of support
providing I thank you foreign